in 1947 Armstrong bought a tape recorder
commercial tape recorders were new at
this point he was one of the first
people in America to buy one like
everyone else of his generation who
first got his hands on a tape recorder
he would play with it
he bought it to tape his shows his live
shows so that he could study them but he
started taping conversations with
friends backstage conversations and he
also taped off all of his record library
from his home so he could travel with it
because Armstrong was on the road 300
nights a year and he missed his records
he loved to listen to music he kept the
tapes because he was a very self-aware
person you know he wrote two
autobiographies of his own and he
thought deeply about the meaning of his
own experience so he realized fairly
early on that he was creating a kind of
personal archive of of information
through these tapes by the time of his
death in 1971 there were about 650 reels
of tape they were kept after his death
in a non climate-controlled attic at his
house in Queens and so although
everybody who knew him knew about the
existence of the tapes it was generally
assumed that they wouldn't be playable
by the time anybody got their hands on
them but it wasn't true when the
contents of the house became part of the
Armstrong archive the archivists did
digital transfers of all the tapes and
they were all playable and they're all
in in depending on the circumstances
under which they were recorded very good
sound I was the first person to write a
book about Armstrong who came along
after these types became available to
researchers and it was really an
extraordinary experience Armstrong was a
very unselfconscious man so if there was
ever a point at which he was aware of
the microphone so to speak it went away
early so when you listen to these tapes
you are stepping in the time machine you
are eavesdropping on the private life of
a great important and
conscious man sometimes he's putting on
a little show he does little mock radio
shows there are tapes where he plays
along with old records of his tapes
where he plays records from his
collection and talks about them and
they're fascinating too but the most
important tapes are the candid tapes
where he simply he simply started the
tape recorder during a dinner party or
in his dressing room or in the bedroom
in a hotel room after the show and just
lets it run and whatever he wants to
talk about whatever the people who are
with him are talking about is what gets
taken down on the recorder so I was
fascinated by the idea that these tapes
might show us an Armstrong that we
didn't know in one sense they don't
because Armstrong was a non self
conscious person and when he got on
stage as everybody I spoke to who knew
him told me what you saw was what you
got he was what he seemed to be but in
private he was more candid I think much
more sharp I don't mean sharp as an
intelligent I mean sharp is in in testy
difficult sometimes because he had a
temper that was something that he didn't
show in public he held grudges and he
talks about some of those grudges and
the tapes grudges against musicians he'd
worked with that he thought had
double-crossed him managers or people
who booked him that had mistreated him
he talks very candidly about the
difficulties he had with the gangsters
of Chicago in 1930-31 back when he was
really having serious run-ins with them
he talks about his marijuana arrest in
1930 in California not a subject that
you would go around and give interviews
about in 1960 in the United States you
hear him getting high with friends you
hear him in one amazing tape trying to
get his wife into bed you hear him
talking to girlfriends when his wife
wasn't around you hear him talking about
racism you hear him talking about people
he had loved and music that he had loved
and whatever inhibition he felt in
public about talking about
Matters is gone in these types and they
bring you closer to him than anything
possibly could closer even than talking
to people who knew him and I talked to
quite a few of those people
it's not quite right to say that they
didn't emerge in in one famous episode
he blew up in front of a reporter when
Dwight Eisenhower who was then president
was hesitating about sending the
National Guard and to desegregate the
schools of Little Rock
he was extremely candid on that occasion
but by that time Armstrong was perceived
as being an accommodationist on racial
matters by younger blacks because
Armstrong had the manners of an earlier
generation he was an entertainer he
didn't perform in public with any kind
of confrontational edge there were those
who called him an Uncle Tom because he
had you know some of the comic
mannerisms of somebody who had grown up
with minstrel shows which is perfectly
natural for a man who was born in New
Orleans in 1901 but in the late 50s he
was widely perceived as being soft on
these matters since it's not soft on all
of them when you listen to the tapes you
realize that although he is himself
devoid of any kind of racist sentiment
there's no reverse racism and Armstrong
at all
he is absolutely frank about things that
have happened to him about the anger
that he feels about episodes where he
felt that he'd been mistreated
especially in Hollywood where he was
sometimes treated as something of a
servant on the movies that he made and
he speaks about them with great candor
and great anger and if you already
viewed Armstrong with a proper
historical perspective you're not going
to be shocked by this but for people who
have this notion that Armstrong was some
kind of Uncle Tom listening to the tapes
is an ear opener